I
hello hi
you don't all have to wave that a couple
ways in it thank you for being here my
name is Evans important and I'm very
happy to be the director of mi t--'s new
center for art science and technology
and even happier to be able to welcome
our guests for the week actually the
first and inaugural artist
brought here is part of the center tomás
Saraceno and we are just as a center
getting up and running my co-director is
Lila Kinney and I also want to thank Liz
Murphy who produced this event and Anja
Ventura who did a lot of the writing to
generate interest to get you here it's
been an incredibly interesting and busy
week for Tomas I can't imagine he has
anything left to say but we're going to
make him talk for a couple of hours
anyway I just briefly you've been seeing
slides of some of the events we have
coming up in the spring I hope that you
will take note of these and that we'll
we'll see you for some or many of them I
would just now like to introduce the
host of this panel moving beyond
materiality something we all need to try
to do the head of the department of
architecture here at MIT now dear Ted
Ani and he will bring out the panel
thank you thank you for the introduction
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to tonight's event it's a great
pleasure to be able to make an
introduction for such an occasion
as it represents the best of MIT a place
that not only promises to mediate
between the arts sciences and technology
but in fact to draw out its greatest
potentials I do want to also thank Leela
Kennedy for making this possible and
cast in general for making this entire
week possible cast has been at the
forefront of many such opportunities and
we in architecture have benefited a
great deal from their broad vision in
helping us to expand our culture this is
great
before I introduce tonight's speaker I
would like to first welcome
anton garcia bill who will alongside me
help to moderate and act as interlocutor
for the evening it is no accident that
he is here with us tonight
anton just joined the faculty of
architecture and promises to bring great
maturity and sophistication to the arena
of design and building technologies
specifically within our curriculum with
his teammate at ensembl and their pop
lab Anton's presence has already been
felt in the halls of 3rd semester core
and we've all had the honor of hearing
him speak about his own work and
research for the open house just two
weeks ago
Anton's presence is known on the global
stage and his work is widely recognized
for its invention its rigor and play his
focus on material agency and its
corollary methods of fabrication have
brought new life to ancient ways of
conceiving building protocols while also
while they all while they have also
brought new depth to modern construction
systems of the many protein waves he is
operated on material systems
maybe his reassessment of masonry and
concrete structures remain the most
alarming and seductive in an era where
we can only conceive of stone as Vinnie
years as finishes or as ornament Anton
has brought new weight to the medium his
music studies center the truffle and the
SGAE
headquarters are but three examples that
bear witness to the astonishing ways in
which his studio has reinvigorated a
discourse on stereo de me on the
monolithic and on the colossal not to
mention the monumental while these were
categories previously reserved for the
arena of history and theory looking back
at the Neolithic period or more recently
if you like towards the Romanesque I'm
reminded of the way in which all of this
was Rieti Erised by rudolf Ahura in his
book on the monolith in the 1990s
examining the way in which contemporary
buildings are revisiting one of
architectures core figurative strategies
to inspire complex ways of transforming
both building culture and perception
today if anything Anton's work
radicalizes what l quarry begins to
theorize Anton's own second doctoral
thesis revolves around stressed mass
bringing our attention not only to the
ways in which engineering has advanced
structural agency but also how this has
enabled architectural strategies that
require mass as the basis of their
transformation their communication and
function
Antone's architecture is serious but
it's also deadpan there's no other way
of interpreting his truffle especially
in the way that it is delivered in his
now infamous video of its construction
it has gravitas and weights
metaphorically and literally but also
the lightness of being which brings us
to the main introduction of the evening
tonight speaker tomás Saraceno is an
expert on lightness but with the same
gravitas and weight of our interlocutor
an tone Saracino structures are
ephemeral they're intricate in material
and stubbornly light refusing to be
sabor
by the traditional mandates of tectonics
not innocent to the protocols of
architecture this artist if it is okay
to reduce them to such a nomenclature is
in fact an architect a graduate of the
Universidad de Buenos Aires with a
postgraduate degree in art and
architecture in escuela super super Rio
de Bellas Artes Ernesto de la kharkova
and then again another postgraduate
degree from the Statler hak schooler in
Frankfurt Tomas is if is if anything
over educated in architecture something
that gave way to his interest in the
arts but also offered an alternative
path for architectural speculation and
this is important I like to say that
Sarah Senna had to escape the
architectural profession in order to
undertake a more challenging and engaged
architectural practice but a practice
that had as one of its core ambitions
and motivations to demonstrate the very
power of the architectural discipline in
its ability to transform reality as we
know it today I will not belabor an
analysis of his work he will have the
time to make his case himself however it
may help to situate his work as
everybody knows the architectural field
has itself opened up many alternative
practices in the past two decades if not
more with the installation becoming one
of its main protagonists having even
been institutionalized not only in
various curricula as we have here but
also memorialized in annual events such
as the ps1 series the work of Sarah Zena
may draw traction from this tradition
but it also should not be confused with
it while his work is parasitical to
architecture its best function is to
challenge the very institution of art
and architecture at the same time his
most recent work in Milan on space-time
foam is an exemplary piece of work in
that beyond the material nature of the
installation which is in its own right
quite sophisticated it is an assault on
perception sensation and effect on the
one hand but also on the other a
challenge to the very building
which is its host to the codes that
regulate the building to the social
foundations that form how we use that
space and how it's negotiated in the
tradition of Cristo and drawn Claud one
could claim that the work is not only
invested in the architectural but also
in the political and bureaucratic
protocols that define limit and give
potential to the practice whether that's
the practice of architecture or art
however in the hands of Saracino these
parameters are led to dizzying and
vertiginous results beyond that of his
predecessors with a disarming character
Sarah Senna is not only at ease with his
imagination but also with that of his
collaborators a militant collaborator
each project is precisely composed of a
variety of players from different
disciplines from the arts the sciences
and way beyond he operates with
methodologies that are at once systemic
in their questions but also open to
empirical speculation research failure
and risk each project is an exercise
that it has not yet been rehearsed or
choreographed much of it is tweaked and
recalibrated on-site with an eye towards
public engagement and interaction his
work awaits you with a repulsion towards
the decorum of tour guided protocols his
attitude is formed around pure physical
engagement and negotiation as if to use
architecture and materiality to
challenge social convention and maybe it
is exactly the frame of the art
institution that can offer the
suspension of disbelief to help
radicalize not so much the meson sin of
Saracen or but his very variable
commitment to inventing new
architectural frameworks so without
further ado I have to say it is hard to
imagine a more appropriate visitor to
MIT culture for this occasion and please
help me to give a warm welcome to Tomas
and will thank you for the invitation
it's working yes the microphone yes and
I have to go from the beginning let me
put it here one second and then I yeah
but I see suit hi hello hello yes now
it's working and no game will be like we
said that maybe the lights we will leave
them off a little bit then if somebody
want to sleep that's a good idea at
least I don't see how it is but okay
that's em no and then the other thing is
like a I you know I would like to say I
mean thank you for all the the beautiful
week for all the beautiful words that I
have heard today and enduring this week
and I mean the list of things is I would
say really endless and how inspiring
have been to be here and still what is
to come but nevertheless I mean I think
so today is a little be try to say like
it's more like a again kind of
experiment let's say I don't like to
make presentation and try to explain my
work or it's more about maybe what it
come up to you and what you can imagine
about it maybe it's a trigger of some
kind of imagination other things all of
us have somehow here there and then and
then you know it's like maybe the
capability to build something and
somehow together you know I always
thought like I mean and kind of like to
put troubles myself in this case you
know I know how to stick it to to half
an hour busy minutes now 652 I have to
to get there but I have like it seems of
400 slides this mean we I always thought
like a you know a way to interact
between me which is here which is kind
of somehow boring also but but is to
give to all of you kind of a remote
control and then we know that in half an
hour we have to go through that to it it
does it mean you know when I said when
you start to get bored about what I'm
talking about it slide you know if all
of you kind of click the button you know
I won't before
so to talk something else and it will be
like kind of a very fast forward
interaction between what what do you
want me to talk Oh at least there might
be something related to the images but
but yeah I have to maybe find next time
like so many remote controls but going
back a little B and maybe does it mean
anytime also I mean let's say I don't
know if it work but maybe there is a way
that you can maybe I mean that was the
strict to put down the light not that I
don't see you sleeping but but you can
say hey come on hurry up or or whatever
is going there but but I mean the first
sample maybe is Libby which is in the
same line which I'm trying to to kind of
give this long introduction is about
this work which somehow it's is a it's
kind of a you know closed-loop feedback
loop or a kind of ecosystem which
somehow the wind turbine hurt it work
also ladies but when I put up he
promised the microphone will work in any
position anyway when when when the
propeller is pain somehow charge the
battery in the battery it it may run the
camera and the camera take pictures and
and it somehow you know it's like a the
first kind of complicating is like a
well you know it's like a you want to
take a picture that's a good frame to to
start a kind of a movie or whatever it
might be and but actually there is no
wind this mean there will not be picture
which will be running and because
basically they every time that they kind
of one of the blades go through these
magnetic sensor it's take a picture this
mean you know it's a kind of more like
exercise to try to be myself maybe more
patient or be surprised by things that
I'm not able to see how to perceive and
it's all about this kind of extension or
delay which somehow the art source would
give me on the possibility to Ranger
play that something I mean what it's
happening at the end of the day is like
a you know it's like a basically is a
time lap but it's based on the wind and
the wind power which by the way also
give energy to to the system but you
know for example
you see the moon kind of very smooth
going here then it go very fast the moon
and then the moon disappear and then
appear somewhere else in the same
because there was no wind right for a
period of time this mean is always kind
of at this stage wind base the movie and
you know I'm always kind of couriers
somehow too you know when when now in
the newspaper appeared kind of how was
the glacier I don't know in the 60s the
level of the ice was much higher and and
the picture which was taking at that
moment was not conscious on the idea
that now the ice is kind of melting this
I mean there is kind of archive Allah
and you know or at least it like an over
attempt that maybe you know I'm taking a
picture of something which somehow I do
not take the decision to see these but
somehow you know maybe the wind took the
decision to to document these four then
later maybe in a couple of years I will
be able that something we you don't
think so might change somehow it changed
later but anyway we we go to yet this is
the Bolivia is the salty lake and and
again I think so you know the what it
happened here is again I did I was not
prepared for what it happened somehow I
mean and I let you your imagination also
to follow again I mean what did happen
at night I mean that that's the nice
image and it's okay anyway I was doing a
video again here based on the system
that I was trying to explain you before
but during the night I did you know it
was not enough sensibility but by what
it happened while we were sleeping up
here for almost a month of the lake and
and then most of the time also there is
this kind of foggy situation and then as
you can see there is some wrinkles and
the water it kind of you know I mean the
deepness of the starts that you see
reflected down in the in the the seed in
the floor it's kind of pretty amazing
it's like a super perfect mirror you
think all the mirror you know will not
give the deep plane survey of the
constellation somehow you step like this
and then your oldest I mean in the south
amis later you say three more years and
it kind of start to wrinkle I mean there
is a kind of pretty much immersion
somehow and there is somehow also let's
try to maybe read this kind of
reverberation or
this kind of movement that somehow is
all maybe we try to interpret through
some other samples and work that's good
well and then back in this installation
which is in Italy which is somehow it
happened the same what may be happening
in the salty lake with the Stars but in
this case it happened with with other
people what is happening here is let me
put go back in this one I mean you know
beside like you know like if I move now
you will be moving if you move I will be
moving and then this kind of a kind of
sharing of the space or the possibility
to move and be moved by somebody who you
do not expect expect but I think so the
motor a kind of funny part is like when
somebody entering the lower part in the
entrance one is a big pressurized space
it doesn't mean when you enter in the
lower space you know you got a very good
a very strong wind which comes to you
and somehow you don't know what it
happened but the people which are on top
they say clothes there are because kind
of everything everybody collapse the
system you know is in a very quickly
situation does it mean there is again
you know there is the engagement between
the people which are occurring in
different levels but also with the
people which enter down and somehow you
don't realize that you know how much the
things are related but but if somehow it
works well the other thing which was
kind of a nightmare also is try to to
get the approval of how to how to to get
it to get it there because I mean are
three layers when you put a lot of
pressure in the cube which is seven
thousand cubic meter of of air all the
three levers are squeezed I mean I just
explained I mean I don't have a better
method of order k lasagna maybe because
start to get angry but angry but but you
know there is no space in between all of
them this mean when you enter with your
own body you kind of opened the space
and as big as you are of you enter
between two person then you cannot bend
the space you know which drive kind of a
very simple relationship with a theory
of relativity events you know how much
you have mass of a body somehow
old people with all planets will
born one to each other but you know the
more complicated was to try to speculate
that if we're going to work or no
because you know when you have somebody
on top for example you're going to
squeeze you doesn't mean you have to
move to the other level when you are
here you squeeze the other one which is
below this image there is a lot of
synchronicity between how people it
moves and how much is affected you know
this I mean I'm passionate about the
butterfly effect and how how we might
relate one to channel here here people
up here I will not make to that one but
well this is the drawing for by Paul
Davies when he he tried to talk about
space-time from modern a Pontic scale
and you know it's still kind of in a
dimension which is cast kind of
passionate me I try to understand it and
maybe to reinterpret it in some some way
okay I mean here is also I mean these
guys pretty much in trouble because he
cannot go out from from things
television this mean again you know it's
like a you know there is a lot of
security which we try to avoid it but
you know for these men to go out
somebody else has to go to the bottom of
the installation and then he will be
lift up and then he can get the
staircase in going and go out this mean
it take a while it will be until you
learn you know how you know and then the
other day I mean the another thing which
happened you usually I mean I'm pretty
much you know at the beginning when was
during the installation we try to make a
manual of how to use it because nobody
really kind of is a constant learning
process for me and for the people who
somehow have to take care but you know
another thing is local people usually
like to be together in a space but when
you be together in space it can really
go deep much more than this this thing
it is very difficult to escape from this
kind of black hole situation they were
there was the first time that I ain't
the kind of alone in this guy tried to
come and rescue me but
but I didn't disappear anyway one of the
idea and I think it's also when I came
today when well I received the
invitation of my team which somehow was
a dream also like a student you know you
Lacoste you one of my former professors
you all say well well you have to go and
study and say away go to MIT and somehow
I didn't make you but I'm so happy to be
here today but you know that then the
idea I mean the way how we build this
this work this kind of membrane let's
let's put it in that way is like then
later we might be able to fill it up
with hydrogen and then the idea that it
will be float right well these floating
islands and and here it is well
something like this we are thinking
maybe we will go to the Maldives island
and which when they said we the best
time will be maybe 15 20 years that they
kind of sink down there and then you
know we are trying to kind of coordinate
them and then you know we were talking
today about the idea to add some
desalinization system very very
primitive of how we might be able to
chill out up here but at the same time
drinking water and at the same time try
to talk or enlarge the dialogue of the
piece that kind of engage in the kind of
situation inside and how we might
confront with another scenario which you
have more maybe Latin to concern but
nevertheless I mean it to go back this
it's you know I'm kind of enthusiastic
to try to think that this might be one
of the clouds or might be one of the
ideas of how we might be able to shape
or to think about or and I also to
explain known as the same as by myself
you never said no we are on a spaceship
earth not spinning around the Sun and
all the time there is this kind of idea
to expand the concept of thinking like a
cloud city in kind of a multiple scales
and but it also go back to the
interpretation of what it what might be
where they might be and but basically
what I am thinking very easily we were
in the
planetarium earth and science and then
was kind of pretty interesting also the
speculation that we were say because you
know what I mean the my first question
will be is like is it possible that to
you know like a kind of in in
architecture a scale or kind of you know
I just borrowed the classification of
the clouds to try to simulate how might
be like a kind of a style in
architecture regular Romani gothic or
whatever and say like okay come
ballooning booze City or strata nimbu
CTO of C Rousseau or whatever and try to
see if I mean the question that I posed
I me was was saying like could we
imagine that if if cities are built
let's say like a and each of these fears
is housed and then you know we can kind
of agglomerate one to each other it's
kind of a kind of big mobility of cities
it it might resemble how clouds with as
we see them today does it mean it might
move this particle in a certain way if
we have never buoyancy that somehow my
form as the clouds form based on the
decision that we may have that we want
to be enabled who want you know on the
way from here to South America and and
back you know that we can choose the
path somehow and then we said like maybe
there are some small chamber that we can
drive with some particle and see if the
simulation of this kind of understanding
of possible Cloud City might might be on
that way well this is some of the
interior in Schuyler also was pretty
interesting the conversation of how this
thing might come together well you know
I'm I'm very fan of Grove area to try to
promote again the idea of the biosphere
the biosphere 2 which was in Arizona and
how we might be able maybe to build the
biosphere again but in this case
floating in the air and to scale well
not my different situation here in this
case you know and trying to collect a
direct and flexible solar panel in the
middle some my life fall on the side and
somehow when understand he it kind of
focus or help to concentrate the Sun in
the middle and then it keep going it's a
kind of more structure of how I think so
you know it could it could come together
it's a little bit more technical but you
know there are each sphere which somehow
you know what I am finding out is much
more easy to use simple simple kind of
geometry and then when you join one to
each other it somehow
close the gap and then what I'm thinking
and it basically the same concept of a
wheel of a bicycle right in three
dimensions and when you pull them all
together somehow you get and you can
enter inside of ball and kind of in the
half between the space this is not
floating is hanging on the tree but
hopefully we could get up in the future
this is kind of the same also was in
this case is also led was more difficult
when when the people are up there
because they could not see you really
what's going on there this mean when
when again you know it's all these kind
of pressurized spaces it's pretty
challenging to to understand how the
dynamics are between in between the
people well then why well I've been
working there with a failing bar from
the trinity college and then university
and Europe have been obsessed quite
quite a lot on the area of how spheres
pac-12 each other and take care of the
optimization between the volume and the
surface and how we could manage to you
know just to get to a scale maybe I try
to go and how they could connect one to
each other which somehow you know it go
back to the piece which is now at the
Metropolitan is a little bit kind of
larger scale in this case at 22 meter
meter each and here you go to them to
the mat these were kind of pretty
smaller and all the time you know it'll
be the reference also was like a you
know it's like what is kind of is it
kind of sundial somehow they work which
is somehow you know when the Sun hit one
of the mirror
somehow the site of this kind of a
possible huge solar clock are the
building which are around and then we
speculate a little bit more if you know
kind of pretty fan of Don Pettit
astronaut which is usually make very
funny experiment International Space
Station if he might be able to see the
sunlight also traveling to that distance
is I mean I was pretty much concentrated
or on the peace but at the same time how
you might be able other people to
perceive it disability and it is again
you know the position of these
reflective surface was again trying to
bring back these experience from Zuni no
from Bolivia where you kind of you know
it's a kind of a challenge to try to
perceive how many
reality you can see at the same time and
move I mean to bring it convey a larger
scale it was a little bit too - you know
I mean but basically what his speculate
is like if we have a 1.2 miles diameter
sphere with one degree of temperature
between the inside the outside you might
be able to lift it up in the air take
into account the volume of the structure
and all the material does it mean it's
pretty important you know how big you
know it's not a ram obsesses to do big
things but somehow if you want to try to
fly only with solar energy and be up
only by the by the Sun it kind of need
to to get it be big and then there is
this kind of speculation to try to bring
down the Sun when many spheres are
connected together I mean they very
simple sample is like play with the
laser and see how it kind of bounce back
and then you kind of reach up there and
then try to get it also in a kind of
another scale of dialogue both the same
where I mean the other reason is like
that I'm partially from Argentina I like
to eat barbecue method well that would
be funny to have a second of a huge
solar cooking on top of the net and
people could go there and hang the
sausage and they cut it and this is kind
of a solar cooking that we are trying to
to cook a chicken which is hanging out
there in the Italia color and when we
get to another dimension and here is a
this is one of these solar balloon which
I say there are not many build in the
war this you can build it like if you
are two or three people one weekend for
300 dollars you can more or less put a
man up in the air only by solar energy
whatever means solid Ranger that this is
really the son who heat up the interior
of these is this polyethylene 50 microns
is the normal trash can
I mean this plastic which is over there
it's kind of similar to this one yeah
it's not more thick than this is even a
little bit thinner and we tape it
together and I think so at the moment
that are eighth in the world who could
who have been built based somehow this
there this is a little bit more
particular because we use this Pentagon
and hexagon which the idea to
incorporate aerogel to get more thermal
resistant and to be longer because every
time they come a cloud which somehow I
like to see cloud city but you go down
this has been but you know the idea is
also you will be above the level of the
cloud this means there is a cover and
and kind of move at a certain speed and
you can regulate the altitude also
opening and closing now you'll get a
chord in the middle this I mean you can
go up and down also let it the hot earth
go through here here's the interior what
is the Rope that you pull this more
similar to a hot air balloon well this
is kind of a project which I'm part of
somehow and it's kind of a collaborative
but let's put it away platform is called
mu zero solar at the moment it might
change to something else and that's a
kind of funny statistic no it cost more
to the cycle back and to produce a new
one this is a Chicano because a better
side cost 4000 to psych 112 Leslie which
can then be sold for c'mon 32 oh my god
that's crazy
anyway well by the end you know they end
up in the vortex or specific with all
the plastic bag and and there but then
what we start to do is like a kind of a
collect plastic bag it's kind of a the
project kind of grow always somehow to a
conversation and and then we kind of
tape them and then it goes up again with
with the Sun and different shapes and
there are different teams in different
part of the world which somehow you know
sometime we get together and then this
kind of museum a collection of plastic
bag keep expanding and somehow you know
it's like if they're always a kind of a
different meaning of how you might
interpret it and also the capability to
see that to see kind of a super
commercial trade name how it get
completely decontextualized when you
travel to another country I would say
the sample we were in
in in France and then we I don't know is
like it what is a common supermarket
chain here in America where we'll be
start my hey start Oh Target or some
Hills Israeli right you know resent then
you know you are in a country that tape
taping target target a Keith Haring's
like Andy Warhol is single again you
know kind of another direction but but
it's somehow you know even these kind of
completely popular training when it went
the experience that I receive is like we
went to then to Paris and then somebody
was laying down there and say wow that's
a super cool label record from the sixty
and was target in Columbia you know what
I mean it's like I own it much like it
mean also that you know when you think
like kind of is a super globalized
interpretation of things I think so and
you'll always depend about a distant
that you see because you know it's
somehow when you add at least and I
don't read anymore the label right and
when it's flying up there he also it
kind of and mostly you know it's about
the idea you know to reusing no I mean
when when the museum went to Cuba also
they they have a super highly
consciousness of reuse the plastic that
no and and not maybe to recycle which is
kind of different I mean and they
proceeded potentialities a plastic bag
have some how to to last
what that'll be another project on if I
will end up here but but was more a
there was a competition in architecture
which as they said have been formed and
then was the idea of proposing a mobile
clinic for prevent HIV in Africa and
then I thought like well one of the
methods that today exists is is a condom
right and to to blow it up and then the
idea that also you know it could somehow
reach also some distinction which
sometimes is difficult to be reached and
at the same time kind of maybe you know
engage the dialogue in a kind of a
different system you know my father was
all the time kind of working for United
Nation and and I've been growing up like
going to developing countries and you
know the first thing I thought like you
know they say the European you know will
arrive with a small tract and saying
well today we will talk about HIV or how
to prevent and left and right and and
then you know it's like in this kind of
maybe cultural context
people they do not even talk about sex
which is most of the case in some of
these countries this I mean imagine
opposite you know arriving kind of kind
of a huge kind of in you don't know even
if it's a condom you know it kind of
mean might be kind of driving some
attention you know people coming to the
square getting up in the thing and you
know it's like maybe engage people in
kind of another level of conversation
and how they could appropriate or think
about something mmm these are who skip
it and maybe they one of the well there
was the piece in Venice which somehow
start with the idea to to kind of rein
interpret I mean what what was was
mostly was this idea of which I which I
kind of read all the time was about the
idea of that many scientists use or
writers or Astro physician also they
always talk about the origin of the
universe or the cosmic web and then the
best analogy that I find is always in
relationship with a with a with a
spiderweb in a three-dimensional
spiderweb this mean what what it happens
is a you know I got very simple up here
is it focused Pringle for Max Planck
Institute we went there we visit him we
start to talk about him and they have
done this thing which is called the
millennium simulation which is the maha
somehow the more precise simulation of
the original the universe and then kind
of keep actualizing all the time and
that well what we did we just bought
like an oven a black widow who came to
the studio and we put it inside a box
trying to think that by reproducing a
kind of a Oh try to kind of rebuild a
three-dimensional spiderweb we might
understand something your relationship
of how the geometry of the universe it
done this mean what we did then in one
moment also with Peter a girl from the
sinking Bell Museum it's kind of famous
a technologies what we try to do is kind
of a hybrid also between different
spider we put first a black widow who
make a kind of type of web then we took
out the black widow and we put at a
canary on top and then what's going to
force
which are kind of solitary they're not
social they do not build well together
but how one species will build a web on
top of the other web and then was pretty
interesting and then they're
acknowledged so ah that will be
interesting anyway we got very
concentrated also try to build only one
here where we computer tomography try to
really you know the thickness of the
spider web is 0.008 thousand of a
millimeter and in the the best machines
that we could find and I think that no
no best not not micro CT scan but kind
of this scale or you know the dimension
of the of the spider web yet you cannot
really this Amin you know we start to
ask to a lot of laboratories and and one
of the most specialized if I'm not wrong
is is some well chuckle from a
university in Basel he's very keen
person on understanding what they were
doing try to also I mean spiderwebs you
can always divide it and be dimension
and three-dimensional in kind of not
very scientific but it's kind of used
always it means never be dimension
because the river always on vacation but
what we figured out that nobody have
ever scan a three-dimensional spiderweb
or kind of digitalized or try to
understand more precise the merging
properties over of a three-dimensional
spiderweb the mineral the exhibition was
coming up you have to present it in the
venice biennale was was this invitation
and we could not find even a method to
to start to scan it for then be able to
rebuild it this mean one day what we
were doing here was with the laser scan
just illuminate one of the boxes and
then when you eliminate we discuss you
can see exactly the intersection point
with the laser and the web this means
based on these then we went to the
secondary museum to the Technical
University in that abstract to the
photogrammetry Institute and then we
asked them to kind of help us to make
this photogrammetry system where we will
take you know in parallel into machine I
mean is a project took two years to to
retest this mean was quite a long
process here are some of the slides here
are all this kind of
parts of the of the scan and then even
we were trying to make many scripting in
the computer and try to kind of connect
some of the and threats and finally we
had to do it all by hand because we was
never working so properly the scripting
and then based on this then we there was
kind of somehow building it this is mean
we got this kind of enormous amount of
of numbers and nodes and intersections
and then I mean we can drive then later
exactly how we do it but you know every
time that there is a two or more lines
reaching to a point we put a vertical I
will print all the nodes on the floor
and on the ceiling this mean we know
exactly where the nodes are happening
and then what we put a nylon line at the
high where the nodes are and then we
start to build from one node to another
node from and here because what it
happened you know when you pull one
thread this thread might be for carrying
three and then four and in five this
mean is very difficult if you don't have
the exactly position on space all the
time where the nodes are located is very
easy tend to pull into the formal
Dannette in another position you mean
the nylon threads and then you have to
navigate kind of through through through
the web also which was pretty completed
here you can see mostly how was that no
it comes from from the Florentine
how somehow start to elevate up in a
three-dimensional space yeah
was worth it was endless work I mean it
was winter outside snow and then we have
to heat it up there
and also I mean I'm now I think so on
Monday I meet somebody here at MIT who
specialized on spiders and I'm very
interesting to start to see and to share
some knowledge and maybe I can give them
the data of this spider web and then see
how it's going now yet people were able
to enter also what it happened later you
know it's like I mean there was many
kind of disciplines working on it each
of them make their own scientific paper
only the ones who kind of had to develop
the kind of the system to to make the
scan Peter Yaeger from the sink every
Museum present the project in a paper in
a Congress World Congress of an
acknowledge in Poland then when I meet
Jill Clemente from he do is responsible
of a lot of life science experiment on
the International Space Station when I
was at NASA in 2009 and he said oh you
managed to scan a three-dimensional
spider web and say well yeah don't send
it to ISS no and then he said wow that's
fantastic because somehow it my kind of
send spider back to space and see how
because before it was not sent I mean
spider have been in space and in a
microgravity environment but always be
dimensional never three dimensions issue
they could not really study them they
will not make sense to maybe to compare
them but somehow also what I like in
that you know we supply this and we keep
going on now there is somebody in Japan
which is very obsessed about like that
all kind of connection our planner and
not happening a three dimensional page
this mean he's writing another paper on
kind of the different interpretation of
the same work but what somehow it kind
of a or the time kind of fascinate me is
his idea you know it's like a you know
most beautiful talk with Jerry Friedman
the other day in his laboratory you know
say it's something that he all the time
also said you know like we know only
four percent you know things that we
have named ninety-six percent still is
black matter or dark energy and all the
rest in which four percent the human the
planets the hydrogen the helium and I
mean a new my know much better than me
what's going on there but somehow the
analogy that people have found to try to
explain the region of the universe is
kind of three-dimensional spiderweb
which somehow you can find in every
corner
my house which had some the same time
was so less study maybe as we know how
the universe is then somehow you know I
kind of like this kind of knowing they
are knowing they're knowing that knowing
the analogy that you find also it's less
known what you thought also at the
beginning they well this'll be their
papers and well this is one of the I
think so the last images where we are
kind of trying to build again the space
elevator based on what some ideas out
there but things let's see I think so
more arrests are made in home time thank
yes Anton I will let you lead the
questions and then I will hold them back
from this side as you as you start okay
Tomas I think there's something that you
can't avoid
yeah is that you were trained as an
architect so that leads us some
questions about your my point of view
main work environment you you operate in
space but you are mmm
you're a racing part of the little bit
rhogam principles no the gravitas
fermitas no booty does and and in this
grinder protection of of our physical
world in that slight line between what's
distinguish our own facility and thus
perience
on this voyage where you operate my
question is that there's always the
present of the exists in the real space
somehow you need this presence to to
express or to materialize the material
is a pain does the person mm oh if I get
more in travel also like too
to define what is material and what is
not material I can maybe one step
backward and then it's always like a you
know what is the process that you could
invent yourself to kind of delay this
capability of perceiving you know and to
try to take into account which are the
players and somehow you know the pieces
somehow also it cannot be trigger this
idea of extending my capability or maybe
the capability of the other ones of how
much role it plays you know it's like mm
I don't know it's like for example in
the piece in Italy you know it's like I
mean it's very simple but you know it's
like there are some some actors let put
it on on on model in the way of how
brunella to try to to define the you
know the kind of the how much you know
the accountability of the environment or
in the India and when we you know it's
like a I don't know I always kind of
tried to delay I mean the I know forgot
the writer of he was a living large in
Tina for quite a long time but he only
time said like look if I manage to
concentrate myself for 30 minute just
looking at this glass and now and I do
this excess just to look at this my life
will be completely different you know
and I completely agree on these you know
it's like it's like how much I extend
can kind of extend myself my ability to
look at something right and these it
might change again and then you know
it's like a I don't know if really
answered the question but that's
something which can obsess me somehow
but to some degree it begs a follow-up
question of who you think your audiences
often as architects you operate in two
worlds one you build buildings for the
general public for people to work in to
rebel in to demonstrate in in other
words it has many publics but another
level of discourse one could say is a
Methodist source you design for a
particular audience even not even all
architects you may be - for people
although I know people who people who be
parallel universes I don't know
do you have an audience that is internal
to your circle whether it's art
historical or whether it's architects
but they are the the Bears of a certain
discourse to which you compete with
aspire to etc hmm and not really I think
so and I hopes I will never have it like
it's so classified somehow and you know
it's like only time you know it I hope
so you know it's like a how to say is
like a what I always think like a me you
know I'm kind of always fascinated you
know how Internet have been invented and
let's put it like this membrane let's
put it like it's more like a platform
for people then to kind of engage maybe
in the construction of something which
might be like a kind of and architecture
I'm interested in kind of a social space
whom I engage people in kind of a
sharing some problems possibility of of
of thinking about something but but is
the audience I mean are my audience all
the time I'm a you know I cannot
separate it so much you know so I cannot
separate so much you know disciplines
I'm kind of much more interesting to
kind of read what is in between or let's
say I'm not so much interested or I'm an
architect is well what we have in common
more that we may operate together and do
something that you know that was
struggling much more and
and boy and what make us you know do
this either way I mean there
acknowledges might be interesting
something I will have another
sensibility but somehow we could
collaborate all together and manage to
do it and each of us you know then
scientists made their papers and I they
were to part of the exhibition and in
something that is but the audience in
this case was very diverse and you know
it has more successful let's say I will
feel myself is how much we can engage in
a kind of a possible dialogue and that's
what for me is architecture is
architecture it's not like the
constructional space architecture you
can say expand it to the construction of
a poetry the architecture of poetry the
architecture of a computer system their
architecture of musical piece oh but but
you do make choices for instance at some
point you had to decide whether the
spiderweb was this thin or that thick so
there there are certain uh priorities
that go with certain specifications
against which you critique yourself and
this invariably involves a larger
discourse so it's it basically I'm
asking how you insert yourself into
those critical decision-making processes
but I think sorry I never do them alone
somehow I hope so I mean the first thing
why we choose a black widow because was
the I mean at the beginning was supposed
to be the piece which goes to Venice and
the Black Widow have a kind of
configuration which somehow I have kind
of a very cowardly agape I mean all that
acknowledge gets you completely piece of
me because we put the black widow upside
down how we present it anyway they see
how a spiders that always happen you
know we have a kind of internal
discourse of dispute about why the
spider is presenting the opposite but
first was you know let's use a type of
spider who who the geometry also will
allow people to walk through and somehow
we will get entangled somehow but also
moved isn't mean the decision in that
case was together with Peter yoga then
this decision of the material you know
did the spider determine the geometry or
did you edit and editorialize some of
know we have many I mean we have like in
maybe 15 or 20 boxes does it mean in
some moment yes we decided which one is
the more beautiful I mean completely
conscious and then also when we try to
mix this hybrid spider oh go make spider
collaborate on one web on top of the
other web also you know we say what that
that's I mean let's start for something
more it's simple and then hopefully the
next we can make more hybrid but but
also was very complicated I mean it was
trial and error trial never you know
it's like a spy at least the Black Widow
thinks I have seven different types of
threads one which is more elastic the
other one who have their computer and
was very complicated to I mean all the
threats we will do a system which is too
flexible it was very difficult to
calibrate this I mean we make all the
lines are non elastic but the nodes and
when they connect are elastic this is
mean it gives some kind of flexibility
to the system still to to kind of have
this ability to to kind of keep the
nodes in this page you it was very
interesting that you showed us the
process to write for example to the
spider web project in a very scientific
method long but I think that behind that
scientific method there's the desire of
managing the uncertainty of of
everything that happens now to really
manipulate and also I seems kind of a
contradiction between the final result
of your work with the way you show the
very scientific process now I think the
the attractive of of it no could you
explain how you how you managed in you
know that long two years scanning
process of a web
so the scientists second figures and
finally when you'd go and work yeah how
I mean it's like I mean they what I
start is like a kind of a I'm it might
be computer when you talk with our
technologies you say hey I want to build
a spiderweb because I'm interesting in
the universe and I'm tried you know and
then I showed a millennium simulation
that ignites the aid I couldn't find a
spider who made the universe you know
like I have nothing to do this analogy
that others
yes give it for granted but at the same
time you know it and Di's it you know I
come you know my messing hey but let's
try it first because you are saying that
it's not similar but actually you never
even scan it at this stage this mean is
also like a kind of a you know and now
maybe we can compare with a little bit
more level of precision between both and
I kind of maybe explain you again in a
kind of work but I we never put it I
mean once again is like I'm not
interesting to say oh I explained to you
in a scientific matter voice explain to
you an artistic matter I think so what
unify us is this passion these
curiosities interest it's like oh let's
do it I don't care in the way how I do
it I water the listen I don't ask for
myself how I do you think you know it's
like a that's what I think so it kind of
blurred disciplines also and blur you
know the wish of to is something you
know I don't know that that's what I as
I found it somehow yeah but to me in
that blur you are proposing a new ways
of occupying space know by the presence
of that structure that construct and
somehow Kennedy generates a landscape
that conditions that constrains the
experience or the way you innovative
yeah in the preserving meal and you were
telling about the full social spirits of
rebalancing of close the door no because
that different of pressure was
generating the moment of power there's a
there's a full narrative in yeah you
know that scientific process yeah I'm a
mom but you know I like something when I
think it's like what the hell is space
you know I don't know
hugs the only problem that I mean I'm
stopped even before you know it's like
and then I read string theory and then
you know Dave
Brian Greene is always explaining the an
another dimension because the spider is
able to walk in a cable in in a kind of
a multiple dimension then I make the
parabolic flight when you are floating
out there you know it's like I don't
know what the hell is still space
somehow and I don't know how many them
dimension you might be able to keep
finding and expanding my imagination
try to somehow to not even to translate
but I think so to build together kind of
an imaginary capability to expand also
you know the way how we how we see the
things you know in our work and you know
and I think is a lot of influence also
of the things that the 10 later come up
with something which it may be talked a
lot about architecture and how we
navigate on on the space but you know
for example space in the membranes now
on this kind of brain so whatever we
want to use more this cosmic scale it
doesn't exist you are again this lasagna
it doesn't exist
I'm fascinating about the idea that a
you enter up here and you you you open
it you open the space and then you move
up here in the space follows you I mean
that's for me in architectural terms is
fantastic is a space who does not exist
that with my body
it opened the switch very a color a very
kind of perfect
I don't want more space that the one
that I need with my own weight does it
mean I open it up the space follows me
like a science picture moving for me
every time I go there oh my god you know
it's like and then I think so that I can
open a space all fancy enough now we
come these guys and I close my space and
I have to move it to the other side I
mean what the heavy space you know is
like it I don't I I don't know but but I
you know it's like a you know is a pure
negotiation between you the other one
the other one is on top the other one
who forgot the door open and say because
this is what it happened you somehow you
learn okay that this space is something
that we can share you know that's
something which you know I love the
analogy to say well I invent all it kind
of whatever architecture is but to try
to kind of promote this idea to you know
that
yeah when you're a kid you always walk
alone when you're in the back you bike
alone well sometime in a tandem but not
you know but also like a how much you
can invent a space which somehow you
know there's this kind of very
straightforward influence of the way how
I move is influenced the way you move
and how you move I move and I don't know
isn't that that's something which you
know is it the space is all the time
invented and reinvented by the way how
how you interact with each other maybe I
get lost
I don't know what I want to say but are
you willing at any cost to fulfill the
this kind of experiments that motivate
these kind of social engagements without
any friction of geometry and those other
things that you hold dear from your
background in architecture yeah hey once
again you know it's like hey I'm already
struggling
geometry know I love topology let let
put in a way that you can and accessing
all the materials that I use somehow
they have a kind of and I know the stone
in kind of 1 billion years will change
as an elastic but but you know like for
example the materials that I work let's
say I would like to rather call them
like it depends I mean and also it's
kind of wrong to try to say what I said
before because let's put it that way if
we you know the same air that you
breathe somehow influence the space that
you are navigating out up there and I
like the idea you know when fuel at all
so think about is huge monster sphere is
just like a by one degree of temperature
between the inside and the outside the
sphere will elevate this is mean like a
I'm trying to transform it something
which kind of a in a very kind of scale
which somehow is you know by the same
breathing of people this the building
will start to fly you know and then it's
kind of this how much reaction of each
singular person somehow doing maybe
something together it might change the
way how we learn to live on the Big
Spaceship Earth that put that way but
but but it you know it's always I mean
the geometry that you for for example
these the insulation in Venice gala
see forming along spider were like a
drop of water on the spider web which is
the title of this paper when they try to
explain the galaxy you know it each
single threat you having in mind not it
was this kind of sphere which instead it
was another sphere and I speak old made
of elastics no does it mean when you
pull one thread this this fear let's put
this geometry kind of deform it really
depends the tension that you put in each
single part which somehow it composed
something and again is beautiful in the
text of Latour this idea of composition
it's something that you know you know
it's something that you you build or you
put more pressure in that in the
membrane which shape have the membrane
it does not have a shape the only what I
could tell you is like it yes have
shapes but because this idea you know
five people anything to make this black
hole that you cannot go out does it mean
but it's a shape which all the time
change constantly constantly I mean
which shape have the air or you know
it's like I don't know I mean you can
constrain somehow to try to give it some
dimension but what you've mentioned
Latour on a couple of vacations and
yesterday I believe you you refer to add
or no and so naturally there's an
intellectual framework around which you
build some of your work we didn't get to
to elaborate much on a doorknob but
immediately I thought from my own
readings about the critical function of
Arts or in its and in its negation alas
pecked to to to reality as we know it
you've resisted on many occasions in
these discussions to to codify to
categorize and to classify but at the
same time you are lurking behind the
scenes there is a you're using art to
instigate to to resist something can you
clarify in your mind either from an
intellectual pedigree or from again a
more intuitive motivation where you what
you think the function of art is can
somebody help me
I say I need a hand today you said I
don't know I did and missing collective
intelligence yeah no whatever no they
won't like it what was like was a
conversation which I have with Daniel
Levinsky actually you know what it
happened like I think somehow lately I
was last week in Berlin which and my
wife is always telling me you see stick
with the architects that's the one who
are inviting you an absolutely the thing
I'm here thanks to you right is like
don't treat bed your own discipline you
know nobody besides I'm very grateful
but no I have what I remember is like
Maura I mean at least in today into the
art scene which I do not find maybe so
much the discourse into the architecture
is this capability to the acceptance of
failure which always Adorno said you
know is one of the is one of the
constitute is Amin is something that you
not a person TC partner you cannot put
it as a it is a condition but you cannot
put it anticipate it on put it on front
and I see many times into you know like
even talking with artists mostly more
than architecture because maybe maybe in
art no maybe because in architecture you
have the responsibility that is a
building that I have to stand that you
know there is something that the failure
is something that I mean you cannot talk
so openly talk about it but in the art
world you know sometimes and unknown
trying to define to divide it the things
that I didn't want it but was these
mostly acceptance to say well it doesn't
work well but you know it's like I don't
say it could fail you know and to be our
heir to fail this is one of the
responsibilities of no but you cannot
put it on on the front and at least
mostly for me is more the ability to say
like a if I if I use this protects that
it might allow to fail
I kind of I'm you know I'm I'm not so
persistent and consistent and kind of
where you mean it's something which are
you and this allowance to failure is it
a matter of scale because now you are
thinking about 1.2 or better down flying
structures you're yeah you're getting
dangerously close to architecture yes
yes on the universe and not of the city
we don't want you to be an architect we
want to stay as you are
right and but a there's a scale of
intervention a space modification of
action that does not resist failure oh
no I mean what what I what I do is like
how beautiful I mean what also is like
and this was a beautiful talk with you
the other day you know it's like there
is this kind of problem let's say of of
scales again but no you know what I mean
it is was nice the other day when we
were talking is like you know this kind
of 1.2 miles diameter this is from one
side you know what it pushed me a lot is
like hey I want to make it fly only with
solar energy and you know the sphere in
this case is the best thing and here
there but but somehow you know I always
thinking like will be so beautiful that
when we think about the city is an
aggregate of very simple and single
houses and you know and that's the scale
does it mean you know the construction
of the city will be the wish of each
single individual did somehow it
generate a big mountain but but again
it's the participation of each single
individual who somehow rely on the
responsibility of each of us toward the
construction of something I mean what
what I'm that has been a city always
yeah
well yes no that's what I would say
completely no that would have been the
city of the neglected I mean it's like
let's say they my role like they put it
on the architectural scale is like how
we could engage people and sit
and everybody engaging the participation
of the urban planning how we can
convince all of you that is beautiful to
build a city now we can build it
together now it's in the hands of
developers for who some time a horrible
thing money there is a kind of a cold
horrible scene behind it and very little
people even architect do not have so
much influence and for me is about how
we can spread or try to engage people
into the construction of the city in
this case a flying city but we could do
also again a normal City you know what I
mean is more about invented platform
let's say how beautiful will be if we
manage to build together as we did Linux
or was this improving Wikipedia
knowledge we could somehow build the
city
a that somehow II you know it's like go
back more to let's say you know Friedman
architecture and mobile and you know
there is a transit tradition also into
the architectures in a scenario of
trying to to involve the people into the
use of misuse of something and I think
that's really something which which I
would love to say more on on a different
scale let me ask you this if MIT were to
offer you a commission of a new building
on campus with the full engagement of
our faculty and student cohorts with you
would you accept the Commission are you
sure the question but I will try to
convince you to make it fly
no but I think there isn't there will be
no beautiful I mean I want with time
thing it's a brilliant I mean it now we
kind of start to breathe be breathing we
go up we go up with job happy lb go we
accelerate hot air you know somehow or
you know it's like a building you know
you come up in the morning and you say
ho which temperatures it which
temperature is today and you see the
building is like so high or so low
because it's like a thermometer in the
city which goes up and down or when you
get tired of MIT you can just take off
your sweater
no but the other thing also what it
drive me crazy in Germany is like a is
the and now is getting the winter in a
bad weather this means something people
travel so you go to Palma de Majorca or
beautiful wet but something you forgot
is like a just few kilometer above where
the same spot you are is a super sunny
day July get up not so far right and
then people travel horizontally but with
the vertical component is it's kind of
missing so man I tell you like a very
small story was I was in San Petersburg
for three weeks and there was no Sun at
all no Sun no Sun no Sun then I got in
the plane finally out and then they
usually in Argentina we still when the
plane is landing we used to clap you
know there is sometimes what's available
it is secret but when it happened in the
plane across the level of the clouds and
people start to clap they saw the Sun I
mean I show my go that's the first
participant you know with them I will
not have problem to convince then I'll
do a cloud I bury above the level of the
car did you mean Tomas you fly when
you're working with the public what may
I use this opportunity to open questions
to your public out here there are two
microphones one on this side and one on
the other side and help to open up this
discussion thank you
thank you very much Tomas this is for
not fantastic I'm not an artist I'm not
an architect I did see your exhibit in
Berlin and getting back to the original
question about who's your audience to me
the audience were the people who were
participating in that exhibit climbing
into the spheres looking at it
experiencing unmitigated delight and I
think that what's really important for
me at least and I had no idea about your
background as an architect is your
creation of opportunities for the light
for delight delight no delight as in
July whatever even oh yeah that too so
like I just well and the other thing
even about the spider about the spider
web that was stunning to look at and
sort of seeing the dependencies and
interdependencies among the various
threats so examining or experiencing
your work and thinking of and from the
point of view of an audience from the
point of view of a participant you
didn't mention social participation to a
degree but to me that is like glooms is
number one and there's what makes your
work that I've seen and that I read
about the project in Frankfurt at the
Ross Market extraordinary and I really
hope that you know you can continue to
focus on that the issues around whether
it's architecture or whether it's
whatever to me are this maybe not the
right thing to say right now irrelevant
see where it takes my breath away but
I'm just curious how long wanting your
work takes my breath away I'm dislike to
touch by your work but I would like to
know how long someone is able to stay in
your occupy your space how long can you
know in name in the web I had space in
your space where the people are I'm not
sure that that would eat only one of the
beginning yeah anyone how many hours
days our cabinet oh okay
no I always thought like it you know
this museum during the night did not
have really like a function and I say
why we don't make it kind of a hostel or
hotel that people could go there it's
like a huge matter is we could sleep all
together you but not usually I mean the
heavy timing it's like a I think so half
an hour you can be up there and then you
know like they have me otherwise you
know I don't know I don't know what will
happen actually but but but there is a
timing that you get inside you get a
number and then for 10 happy now when
you can be there and then go out and
then but alway will say like a on the
top or one of the levels but on the
bottom you can stay as long as you want
this mean also you know my mother never
went up there you know it sure is like
hey up down yes
um in your conversation with Nanda and
ento before you you keep like resisting
there your work from like architecture
um so I'm just curious about like
because in your work you present a
really strong connection with
architecture actually like and share
that idea of like social space there are
gravity there public engagement and this
ideas just come across like the art and
architecture and I'm just wondering um
how do you think your previous
architecture education contribute to
your work or um in another way to put it
like how do you think your work will in
turn contribute to other architectural
approach and no I don't know so much but
maybe you know much better than me oh
how you know it's like mm maybe you can
tell me
I mean you we have been together with in
the conversation with know in that in
that when we were with Skylar together
no you were not that no
I know I mix it up but
what should I answer I don't know no I
well
next no but what is your an architect or
what you study architecture yeah yeah
it's super I hope I hope so we can
influence each other all the time we can
build it well no I mean what was is like
when we were at I was the other day at
the Media Lab also trying to convince
them to help me on get some sense not to
measure the temperature of people when
they're up there not because the media
level so there is this kind of strange
intersection also of how they put all
these sensor on the building up there
and then and how you know you can track
conversation or temperature and that was
up for me will be pretty useful too
because the problem is like when you
have to rescue somewhere there that it
never happened yet right but but in case
and also is like how much information
you give to the person to be able to to
move into that space now let's say on
this big air moving this mean usually
what I always tend to say is like you
don't have to say nothing to them let's
put it that I'm trying to answer your
question on architecture no it's more
about like which information is
necessary to give to somebody and if is
necessary to use or misuse this space in
that in that way in that space that was
created was there a usually they are
very severe with me they tell look the
public first take out your shoes
take out everything from your pocket
because we might make a hole you fall
down 20 meters don't go to the border
don't get together so much don't do this
don't do that
at the ends like oh my god don't tell
this to the people you know I hate this
kind of you know is it space that you
may experience and at the end is
contradictory also within a same nature
of how people might be able to
experience it and to learn from kind of
a feedback a relationship between us
know or between how it's used on these
you this mean I thought like you know
whether maybe with a meteor it sensing
and then is much more less responsible
because when you enter the space and I'm
always talking about architecture and
they tell you all the things that you
can do and you cannot do somehow you are
enter much more confident because you
say oh they told me I can do this they
told me I can do that you know and then
you move if I would they strategize I am
always time trying to to avoid is like
it don't tell nothing to the participant
who are there when they enter there they
are kind of oh my god what the hell is
going on you got war you go down you
know it's like somehow the learning
process is much more your responsibility
toward a space or towards a planet let
put it that way it's much more engaging
and what much better you know it's much
more attune you know it's much more
sensible so I had a question about them
the talk is called beyond materiality
and um it's really fascinating but so
basically so this this space which is
the negative then there's the solid
object would change the space and so we
if it's beyond materiality that
materiality is a wrap back around that
the space is the primary investigation
and it seems like that's you're really
interested in the space but like Nydia
was talking about something has to shape
and define that space and so for example
the plastic sheets to find the different
layers and how people move with the
space close behind you is actually the
mylar sheets that would close behind you
so the materiality is it just whatever
is needed to create the the environment
or like is it just that the whatever you
can get your hands on whatever is
actually does the job like that I think
there was a question about what
thickness of thread you'd use for the
spiderweb was it just whatever you was
available or you said okay this is too
elastic this is too stiff so this one
works so it's just there was no kind of
amun over thought about well this is the
material just that well this is what
works best to define the space and
create you know the environment yes
no about material I'm here I enjoy also
MIT I mean we visit with Leila it was
fantastic many experts on different
materials you know for example would be
wonderful if but these these nano
graphene tubes are not still available
to buy lot to happen I'm trying to build
now a flying plaster there is this a or
again this graphic graphene no these
sheets very very light if I will get
these to make next solid balloon will be
much more smaller and it less volume
less material but still is not available
this meaning is a yes a negotiation or
always you know I mean the sheets that
I'm using at PVC will be nice to make
them with ET Fe which will no less more
much more longer I don't know if it
answer exactly the question but I guess
your plane focuses the space whatever
shapes the space yes whatever it needs
to be yes yes yeah but let me put it
again for example in mu zero Solara no
this is a kind of huge museum which fly
made of reuse plastic bags also the
material over there you know it's like
him people bring it or people tape it at
their home and the space also is
something which is pretty undefined
because it's due to collaboration of the
persons that the space keep growing and
the collection it keep growing and some
of us these days let's say put it in
architecture is always this problem that
sometimes architecture build a museum
there is too big for the collection or
too small for that collection and you
know you don't have enough space then
you show these are and you don't have to
change I mean
it's beautiful this museum soma always
show all the collection which is a
plastic base somehow and you keep
growing because every time you add more
it can get it bigger and get it bigger
and and I think so that's also like a
space which just grow through the
participation of people orchid is small
you know now at the moment are three
museums one in Helsinki one in Italy
when Germany sometimes what we do before
there were many more and now we glue
them all together and the space you get
bigger as bigger in case of more lifts
is there will be a moment maybe you can
carry a person up there also but but it
also changed and if this is also nice to
you know you know when you see it you
see every single piece you know somehow
you you get the idea of how it's done
somehow maybe the materiality of it now
which is we get really personal so now
you know over Santa Maria in Colombia
managing and n every situation of
culture or scenario it completely change
also how its appropriated some ago Santa
Maria was in charge of many community in
different favelas in both in medicine
and in so you know we will ask inhuman
worship for for with children and then
they were kind of musing like to make
drawings on top and then you know
everybody do something then when we were
at Minneapolis in named San Luis because
we wanted to let it fly and then we
start to work with somebody retired
person from NASA and then they FA a
federal are you know take a vacation you
know to let fly such a big chunk of
plastic you have to have a way to bring
it down this mean we build a sense or to
kind of cut it and then I don't know you
know also space you know because you
have to fly but not interfere with the
airplane that's another space you know
the space you occupy
yeah I'd like to draw attention to the
fact that in almost every picture we've
seen there's a human being and it might
be like an obvious fact but I think it's
important to stress it in the
conversation because it addresses also
the thing of the audience the
architecture and the materiality because
even in even in Venice with the spiders
there's in the picture that we saw there
is this guy standing next to it with a
little plastic shoe protectors and the
true protector is creating like a
distance from the floor so that the
floor Tessa doesn't become a floor by
getting some dirt on it and so that we
can still see the light which is the
same white so that the man who is
looking at the thing and is pondering
this by the web is like floating in that
air right so I I seem to identify this
importance of the human being that the
balloon that is floating with the Sun
there's somebody hanging there's always
somebody there being floated by the
material and so the question of the
materiality is also related to this
presence of the human being because the
human being is very real very material
very very they're very physical and it
is a whole collection of devices to
bring this physical person into a nim
material atmosphere
is that a conscious search or is it
something that I'm just seeing no no I I
love to I love people Steve no no but
I'm I'm I'm disappointed you know I
think so tomorrow is a no when is they
all match to Enrico Fermi that Friedman
head
Hey monday monday 3:30 hehe oh somebody
have wrote a book based on one of the
sentence that he always said where is
everybody
right where is everybody
and then and then I will tell you now a
story which kind of rephrase may be the
same which I think so is a story
bryceton is LM written in a Carl Sagan
book I don't know if it's Voyager or
some of the other one and then there are
people on always about people I'm
telling you there are people on the
planet Earth trying to see if there is
life or there are other people in
another planet and then the first what
they do there are so astronomers will
put away they build a telescope of that
science now and then they look oh there
is nobody up there then next year they
build a telescope will be bigger
they look again oh there is nobody up
there then the next year they make it a
little bit bigger ladies they look or
nothing at it and then the telescope
keep growing growing growing out there
is a moment that the telescope is so big
that the other ones see first the
telescope and we through the telescope
see the other one you know what I mean
you know and I love this idea of you
know and it's again you know where is
Africa you know I wish we might be able
to take into account more you know even
beyond this is this planet and maybe
thank you I have a two-part question
about the spider web in Venice the first
is a very MIT kind of tech question and
I'll add asked the other one later the
structure once you have the map of what
the spider did and you have your thing
you wish to create you have so many
degrees of freedom it's very very
difficult to make it so as you were
putting it together what was more
important to you what was your priority
the topology in other words this node is
connected to this node is connected to
that node or where the node ended up in
space that's that question weapon no I
was pretty much obsessed to try to build
as perfect as possible you know that I
don't know to answer the first question
and then the other I think so I always
think you know it's like it was an
exercise just I want that this no rain
happier and go here and there from here
it go here so you kept going until
everything was right I want to became a
kind of spider way okay so the second
part of the question is more
philosophical for you what was the most
important part of the art developing the
method to make the spider web or the
finished web the art for me was really
like it to build these web between
relationship people again maybe the
people were not so visible but they kind
of a beautiful spirit of collaboration
that we weave between us that was really
the work which is invisible again but I
think so that's that really dragged me
complete when we was
beautiful which is not even in the world
but somehow show that this was possible
thanks to something which is
unaccountable new friendship or whatever
is but I think so that's really that's
really the work I think so thank you
thank you um I have a question which is
we you've talked a lot about sort of the
importance of the sort of social
interaction and the sort of people
occupying the space but you've also
mentioned briefly how sort of the
institutions where you're placing these
works have asked you to make compromises
in how people are using them when and
how do you decide what compromises
you're willing to make is always a very
like a you senses yourself now say until
you know something they ask you no no no
no in one moment you explode say okay
maths I don't want to do it you know but
otherwise you kind of you you always
accept some things some not but mostly
the things like what I try to do is
never being myself and then there is the
institution so we work together right
from the beginning you know because
mostly our project which are liking it
cause like it 30 times more budget that
they offer me do you mean if they don't
want to do it from their side it's
almost impossible right from the
beginning to do it you know because it's
really like a this mean they're very
very engaged from the beginning because
usually it's a little bit more ambitious
and there is this kind of architecture
scale in some of them which kind of you
know also you know in sometimes
institution also are not so used to work
at that scale which also kind of get a
lot of troubles also for you know
curators and museum and this is
different because it's like oh my god
and me also somehow because I never
really practice architecture so
straightforward this in main name it
come together somehow always some
something so are you saying your art is
in upping the budget 30-fold say they
said we got my commission yeah well we
have time for one more question and then
we need to wrap it up
hi hello I discovered you on Sunday and
I am not affiliated with this school or
architecture at all so I see that your
work exists an outside space and inside
space
do you enjoy or are you more inspired by
a space that's like really fast with so
much potential or do you enjoy the
limiting spaces that are smaller or any
like interior yeah no both I think so
and always you know the space inside
your brain is like a columns you know
there is always this analogy also the
spider web many you know how it is we
are visiting somebody who is
specializing in connectomes on Monday
and then it's kind of the inner you know
connectivity of of cells and and this is
mean I think so you know you know there
is you know it's kind of this
simultaneously you know simultaneity
between the appreciation of this
multiple scales which which kind of make
me enthusiastic and then then you know
when it doesn't work in one scale I said
well you know in my work in some other
scale inside my brain or inside they've
been or somebody else or or something
that is Tomas you've been very generous
with your time and your thinking you're
still here so people have more access to
them I just want to thank you again for
this wonderful
you